hey gq i'm dr jordan newen i'm a
biomedical engineer inventor and
futurist and this is the breakdown
[Music]
[Applause]
in this episode we'll be breaking down
robots in future tech
iron man
you're going to start off nice and easy
you're going to see 10 thrust capacity
chief lift
and three
two
one
i love that seed just the way that tony
stark goes about designing the uh the
thrusters to his his uh suit to allow
him to to fly
he just goes straight in and tests it
what i loved about seeing these movies
was i was going he designs things the
way that i do he tests them out he
crashes them he hurts himself in some
cases in university when i was doing my
phd i was designing a wheelchair that
could be controlled by the power of the
mind the wheelchair itself was a robot
so it needed to be able to see and think
for itself the first time i got my
wheelchair to operate i didn't think
anything was working i didn't think i
had
the program controlling the motors yet
so i started eating my lunch i sat back
in my seat and i ran the program to see
what would happen it took off and not
only did it take off i had the voltages
completely wrong it also took off at a
fast speed through my screen off the
table unplugged itself when it uh it
took off towards the wall but not in
time it actually went through the wall
of the
uh the office that i was in uh and then
when uh iron man came out a few years
later i started realizing he was
designing things the way that i did and
this is all part of it you design you
test you usually try not to hurt
yourself like that but then you iterate
three two one
we'll pause it right there
i love the detail they've gone into in
this scene so exoskeleton technology is
something that's always advancing
exoskeletons being able to wear some
sort of suit that can help you with
strength or can even
help people who might have a spinal cord
injury or not be able to to say move
move the legs be able to stand and
potentially walk i've seen all kinds of
of exoskeletons getting smaller cheaper
lighter faster they operate a lot better
than they used to and they'll eventually
get to the point of being able to just
wear uh wear suits as well where some
sort of outfit that looks like a a lot
more like a material in this case he's
got this metal exoskeleton he's trying
to take on that next level of iteration
in his flight he's trying to control it
a lot better the level of detail that
they've got in this scene is just
awesome because we've got even those
little side thrusters that help
stabilize his legs as he's taking flight
i think that was just an amazing level
of detail that they've they've paid
attention to we should take another look
into arc reactor technology
the arc reactor that's a publicity stunt
tony come on we built that thing to shut
the hippies up we'll pause it there so
this arc reactor it looks very much like
a hydrogen fusion tokamak and even
uh jeff bridge's character there over
dyer he's saying it's a publicity stunt
it's almost a take on where hydrogen
fusion is at and what's happened in the
past it was always touted as being the
energy of the future and always will be
or
the energy that will be 30 years away
and always will be so there is a big
international collaboration called ita
iter
and this is where many countries have
come together to try and realize this
potential future energy of hydrogen
fusion different to nuclear fission
reactors where you're breaking apart
isotopes of something like uranium or
plutonium in a hydrogen fusion reactor
this kind of works the way that
the sun almost creates energy itself
you've got a donut shape and that donut
is a vacuum and so they push a hydrogen
gas into that vacuum and it's surrounded
by electromagnets so magnets with huge
amounts of energy going into it to try
and contain and hold that uh that
charged uh gas in place so that it
doesn't touch the sides because they
heat it right up and they can heat it to
a plasma that gets to about 150 million
degrees celsius we're talking 10 times
the surface temperature of the sun here
and to get to that level of
heat and pressure what happens is
hydrogen atoms start actually fusing
together they convert into helium
there's a drop in mass and a massive
release of energy and you can see here
in the arc reactor in this scene it has
big donut shape so it's got that tokamak
style
shape to it it's even got little rings
which look like uh they're the
electromagnets but in a tokamak the way
it tends to look is they just tend to
look like a giant dome and it really is
a holy grail of energy generation so
this is why it's been in the movie and
the arc reactor resembles that
ex machina
[Music]
caleb
you're wrong so this is
chilling scene it's an amazing movie
it's a modern take on the touring test
so this was designed by alan turing in
1950 the whole idea was that a person
would interact with an artificial
intelligence in the future at some point
where an ai could sufficiently dupe a
human into thinking they were
interacting with another human if they
could be sufficiently duped then the
turing test would be passed by this uh
this advanced level of artificial
intelligence now this has come up over
different points in time like uh ridley
scott's 1982 blade runner the androids
in that movie were tested with something
they called the voitcamp test and this
test was to try and bring out levels of
empathy they would look at the eye they
would look for pupillary dilation so the
response that the android would have to
being given emotionally evocative
questions whereas ex machina has taken
this to a whole new level and this is
what i absolutely love about this movie
caleb here is speaking to what is
clearly an android they're not hiding
that so what is happening here is it
seems that ava knows that she's sentient
that she's cognitive that she's actually
uniquely experiencing her environment
and that she's conscious she's trying to
convince him of that fact at this
particular point in time where ai
becomes somewhat
sentient when it can
exhibit that level of human
characteristic where it's able to
perceive its environment um interact
with that learn independently but also
show that level of sentience of of
self-awareness
well even though it's not biological
this will start to bring up a level of
robots and ai rights because who are we
to say
that a robot or an artificial
intelligence can't love can't experience
these levels of emotions because once
it's able to
properly trick us into believing that it
is sentient this raises a massive set of
ethical questions that we have to be
able to answer
to uh ai systems whether they're in
robot form or not uh
will they need rights do you think i
might be switched off because i don't
function as well as i'm supposed to ava
i don't know
the answer to your question a robot or
an android like ava
is so advanced it would
be built in a way that utilizes a fusion
of
many different types of sensors and at
the same time trying to replicate those
of humans
and the artificial intelligence many
types of artificial intelligence
interoperating so
ava is able to see out her eyes it seems
it seems like she's utilizing cameras
and uh the same sort of image processing
technology but at the same time when it
comes to artificial intelligence
operating through camera technology uh
it could actually be used to perceive a
lot more than say the human eye there
could be infrared in there as well it
could have infrared sensors so she might
be able to even see in the dark who
knows then there would probably be
haptic feedback so she'd be able to feel
things like uh if say a person was
touching her hand
she would be able to feel that so to try
and emulate the types of sensory systems
that our body has it's very very
difficult because our
our body is just full of so many
different uh
sensory systems sensory input and then
be able to output through movement
through voice through gestures through
human characteristics and mannerisms
very complex technology massive fusion
of many different types of technologies
from hardware to software and artificial
intelligence but these where the
advancements are all headed the
technology is pretty much all there it
just needs to be designed in a way
that's uh streamlined so it all works
together seamlessly and can all fit
including the power systems can all fit
into an android body
but the technology is well on its way
wally i love this movie
[Music]
we'll stop it there what this animation
does so well
is depicts a robot that has so much
personality now this is called
anthropomorphism it's where we project
human personalities and characteristics
onto things that aren't human and we do
this all the time it's why you might say
name your plants or see a face in the
front of a car
this is what we tend to do we project
human personalities and characteristics
onto things that aren't human this whole
idea of how much we like an entity or a
robot or an animation it doesn't matter
what type of entity it is but how much
we like it depends on how human-like its
characteristics are and this is called
the uncanny valley as an entity as a
character becomes more and more
human-like our affinity for it goes up
we start to like it more and more up
until a certain point and then there's a
point in time where an animated
character or a robot becomes too
human-like and what happens is we
plummet down the valley and this is
called the uncanny valley we actually
become scared of it we can become a bit
freaked out and that's what happens if
you see an android that's been designed
a robot that looks very human-like but
isn't quite right because our brain is
able to pick up on those tiny things the
micro facial features all the different
changes the things that we're suddenly
missing out on we can see it's an
impostor and our threat detectors go off
in our brain the only way to come out of
the uncanny valley is to make something
so human-like it's indistinguishable
from the real thing
this is a principle that's used a lot in
animations and movies that i think
the likes of pixar and dreamworks just
get so
right in how they do these things wally
doesn't look at all humans so it's not
along the curve of the uncanny valley
we're not going to get freaked out by it
but it shows lots and lots of human
characteristics in his personality he's
curious he's interested he's creating
his own little space where he's got all
the different gadgets and toys and
things that he's picked up in his
travels that he enjoys
we're seeing him have a bit of a love
for life and that's giving us joy
through being able to see it because so
much of that personality comes across in
those small things those small details
like the look of the eyes the way that
they move
the imperfections like wally has there's
perfection in imperfection because we
actually
like things that aren't perfect it
happens a lot when we're watching these
things we don't want to see everything
that's completely
symmetrical completely perfect our brain
likes those levels of imperfection and
this comes across in the personality of
something like a robot which is why my
robots also get distracted and have that
level of curiosity
ai artificial intelligence
his name is teddy
teddy this is david
[Music]
hello teddy
hello david
david teddy is a super toy and i know
you'll take good care of each other
i am not a toy
i love that i am not a toy the movement
in his eyes the facial expressions it's
what i'm saying you're able to bring
across
personality this whole movie is a modern
take on pinocchio david is a young
android boy who's been designed to
replicate uh the son of of this this
family they've lost their son so they
have an android
replacement and so he's basically like
pinocchio he wants to become a real boy
he wants to become a real human at the
same time teddy is basically jiminy
cricket teddy is the voice of reason for
david and goes on these adventures with
him always sort of working through what
he should be doing what he shouldn't be
doing helping him on that journey and
being his his guiding light robots all
form some form of function that can
in many ways help humans so you've got
the boy david who's been designed to
help in that grieving process so that
the family can have a replacement
whether that completely works or not it
depends on how people obviously deal
with grief i think that we are going to
see
various levels of robots augmenting the
human experience it's never meant to
replace human to human interaction
that's not what it should be for
we get a lot of
a lot of amazing benefits in having
face-to-face interaction our brain loves
and thrives on face-to-face real-life
interactions our brains physiologically
change each other in each other's
presence particularly when we make eye
contact
i robot
i know the three laws your
perfect circle of protection a robot
cannot harm a human being the first law
of robotics yeah i know i've seen your
commercials
but doesn't the second law state that a
robot has to obey any order given by a
human being
what if it was given in order to kill
impossible it would conflict with the
first law
right but the third law states that a
robot can defend itself yes but only
when that action does not conflict with
the first or second laws well you know
what they say
laws are made to be broken so these
three laws of robotics have
uh come up in this movie it actually was
originally created by isaac asimov and
that's why they're called asimov's three
laws of robotics now these actually were
built into his his short story called
run around which he uh wrote in 1942
published in 1942 and this had and
featured the three laws which he also
built into his fictional robots in many
of his other
stories as well
and this is
a governing set of laws
that are built into robots so that they
will help humans they will improve
humanity
and not become our enemy so they're kind
of like safeguards that have been built
into all of these fictional
robots but also basically brought up
this whole concept that we need to think
about when it comes to artificial
intelligence and robotics
that we need to build in these
safeguards we might need to build in
things like the three laws the problem
with it though is that
these laws tend to be very subjective
they can be open to interpretation and
you don't want robots or ai being able
to interpret rules or laws because it
could potentially find ways to work
around it while still satisfying it so
laws will probably need to be made a lot
more specific in this particular case
my father tried to teach me human
emotions
they are
difficult this brings up a much broader
conversation about artificial
intelligence this is an area i've gone
into in my book uh it has been widely
philosophized this this area in the
future this point in time the
technological singularity where
artificial intelligence becomes on par
with human brain in every way possible
where currently
uh you know widely acknowledged we're
currently placed in the artificial
narrow intelligence banned out of three
major areas of ai the next is artificial
general intelligence and we are a
general intelligence because our brain
is incredibly complex it can do so many
different things we are able to uh to
learn various different tasks we're able
to adapt to our environment and
when an artificial intelligence becomes
on par with us in every way possible it
becomes an a
an agi an artificial general
intelligence and it will very quickly
by that point in time be able to take
itself to the next level it will be able
to evolve itself to become an artificial
super intelligence where it goes beyond
human capacity and we suddenly end up
with the new alpha species
so at this point in time things get
really really bad for us or it could get
really really good
and this is going to be based on how we
approach this particular philosophical
point in time
so
really what isaac asimov did was he put
into our minds that we need to be able
to build values build laws build things
into
an ai so that
once it gets to that point
it will actually want to
create benefit for humans for life on
earth and maybe even help us do things
like explore the stars
so there could be mutual benefit in it
but we need to be able to plan for this
before we get to that point
back to the future
uh does it run like on regular unleaded
gasoline unfortunately no it requires
something with a little more kick
plutonium uh plutonium wait a minute are
you are you telling me that this sucker
is nuclear hey hey hey keep rolling keep
rolling there no no no this sucker's
electrical but i need a nuclear reaction
to generate the 1.21 gigawatts of
electricity i need doc you don't just
walk into a store and by plutonium stop
that that's right you don't just walk
into a store and buy plutonium plutonium
isotopes are often used uh in nuclear
reactors
plutonium and uranium are the main
isotopes used for nuclear fission which
is where the isotopes are actually
broken apart by neutrons being fired at
the atom to split it up which releases
energy and releases more neutrons to
continue on the reaction as far as a
nuclear reactor is concerned it's more
or less almost controlling a nuclear
bomb it's almost controlling that
explosion but
pulling out the energy in this case what
they're doing is putting a nuclear
reactor that runs on plutonium on the
back of the delorean to power the
flux capacitor which is what makes time
travel possible in these movies and
allows the delorean to time travel
the delorean beautiful machine and what
actually happened here was the late ron
cobb he was a mate of mine uh he was a
political cartoonist and also a sci-fi
cartoonist he was given the task of
trying to turn a delorean into a time
machine he said once they figured out
where the flux capacitor went everything
else fell into place the original design
only had one exhaust
in this there's two exhausts the second
one to balance it out and also make them
a lot larger
which gives it a lot more balance and
the car looks incredible for it what did
i tell you
88 miles per hour i own a delorean as
part of my production house it is the
coolest thing it's a lifelong dream
first thing i noticed when i got in the
door was it actually doesn't go up to 88
miles on the dial they had to
fix that up into the this particular
delorean for the movie
back to the future too
what the hell was that taxi cab
what do you mean a taxi cab without we
were flying precisely
all right doc what's going on huh where
are we
when are we we're descending toward hill
valley california
at 4 29 p.m on wednesday october 21st
2015. stop it right there 2015
unfortunately we didn't get flying cars
by this point in time they have come up
in some form but they don't look the way
that they did in the movies i would much
prefer a flying delorean to what has
actually turned up i've gotten in one of
them which was a passenger carrying
electric autonomous mega drone it had
one seat had a thing that was like an
ipad in front of you you selected where
you want to go and this would take up
through the cloud straight to the
location and straight down i didn't go
very far in it but i got to experience
it and this was in a quadcopter
configuration so this was a lot like uh
the quadcopters that you might you know
fly with uh cameras on them but bigger
as we just saw in this particular clip
it's a very challenging thing to to fly
a car i mean what sort of height is it
flying at he's going into oncoming
traffic a big challenge for any uh
design to flying vehicles so the
mega drone that i got inside to allow
these to viably fly from one place to
another autonomously they set up
different heights so instead of it being
like different lanes on the road these
will actually fly at different heights
so they can avoid collisions that way
but there has been an iteration and any
engineer any inventor will not only
design a particular solution they'll
start to iterate on it as well and so i
love seeing that in these movies where
doc brown comes out back at the end of
the first movie and it flows into the
second he's got this new design on the
delorean it no longer runs on plutonium
because it wasn't a viable solution he's
got some futuristic version of
nuclear fusion instead so he's got a
misdiffusion on the back they don't show
how it works they just show mr fusion on
the back of the delorean doc brown
throws some soda and some scraps into it
so biological waste and somehow converts
that into energy now fusion is more of a
futuristic technology it's one that is
being developed has been developed for
for many years um in particular hydrogen
fusion is the one that's being looked
into and it could be a future source of
clean energy
wild wild west
the colors around the neck see me
contain powerful magnets as long as we
can outrun the blade we'll be fine good
how long does it take a magnet to lose
its power about 400 years damn
both of these characters have these
magnetic discs around their neck and
they're being chased by these blades so
the blades would be temporary types of
magnets they're probably made of
something like iron which can become
magnetic when exposed to a magnetic
field so in this the magnetic field is
being created by these rings around
their necks
but
not viable to create
that level of magnetism that would
require a power source which they
clearly don't have on their neck here so
it can't really be a
an electromagnet and it would also
require a lot of power this movie is
very much a steampunk style approach to
things no battery source no power source
that would power something that would
require a astronomical amount of energy
to
create a magnetic field that strong that
could pull
these blades towards them another
potential approach would be super
magnets using superconductors
superconductors need to be brought down
really really cold to cryogenic
temperatures to allow the resistance in
the conductors to basically disappear
and then it can create huge amounts of
magnetism in this case
again it wouldn't be strong enough it's
not viable
for it to work this way but it is a
funny scene as we've seen through a lot
of these different clips in these movies
science fiction has given us these
amazing ideas of where the future could
go and often they are dystopic they tend
to show us these darker depictions of
where the future could potentially go so
we can treat these things as warnings
you know we've got to treat them as
warnings for where the future could go
so we can think about them create a
better vision for a better tomorrow and
move towards those when it comes to
automation robotics artificial
intelligence incredibly powerful
technologies that are central to our
day-to-day lives but also will be
massively defining towards our future we
need to as individuals as groups as
collectives as organizations and
companies be able to shape that change
so that's why these conversations are
incredibly important to be able to have
these conversations to work through what
we want what we don't want the ethical
approach to designing these powerful
technologies and how they might be able
to augment the human experience help
humanity and move towards improving all
life on earth thanks so much for
watching these clips with me stay tuned
for part two